welcome back to the iced coffee hour i'm
nick d giovanni this podcast has made
250 000
that's actually probably the closest
guess we've had that was good that was
really good so the real answer is
187
311.
exactly
i was close yeah oh and also one more
thing i want to ask for everyone who's
watching this apparently we're not
asking enough for you guys to subscribe
so if you guys enjoy these episodes we
only post once a week right now so just
subscribe you're not going to miss the
next episode it would mean so much to us
and nick it would i said that before we
started yeah
actually my main sort of concern coming
in that everyone liked the video
it's a really good guess relatively
close i'll take that cool well thank you
so much for driving all the way to las
vegas you were in traffic for quite some
time because uh some people were getting
arrested on the side of the freeway
people got arrested on the side of the
road three or four people in the same
incident right yeah one car just all
against the girls holy bunch of cops
yeah it was bad
i don't know what they did but
it's nice
yeah i hate to say i i'm always the one
who stops i like you really yeah i do
you're a trafficker
yeah yeah
just curious like if i'm sitting in
traffic for an hour
i want to know i just want to know what
am i waiting an hour for
they're going through it and they don't
want people going and looking at them
while they're being embarrassed you know
it's not how can you not look in a way
but yeah you do look i'm not wanting to
stop yeah yeah yeah sure yeah anyway
thank you so much for coming on jackson
you want to give an intro here sure so
this is nick di giovanni everyone you
have
just under 20 million followers across
all platforms you were the youngest
finalist ever on masterchef you got
third place on season 10 you're on
forbes 30 under 30
and it's a pleasure to have you you're
also a harvard graduate i am somehow
that's crazy somehow welcome to the iced
coffee hour this is amazing i'm it's
great to be here i love the table i
can't stop talking about it yeah it's a
cool table it is a table well that's so
cool i had no i didn't know the harvard
bit yeah yeah i was going the
traditional route i was just
i uh
i was studying environmental science
there just something i was interested in
i did i got there not even knowing what
i wanted to do um wait wait we got to
talk about how did you even get into
harvard how does how does that happen
that's a really fair question even i
don't know no i i i did not do well in
school up until high school okay um i
repeated freshman year in high school
and it helped a lot it was the best
thing i think i ever did i just think i
needed that extra year of you know
i need to be a little bit more mature
honestly and i think it helped a ton i
was just developmentally i feel like i
was a little bit better were you young
for your grade like you know sometimes
is that cut off where it's like you know
you could be the grade
before or you could start now and like
be the youngest in your class where you
was i think i was a bit on the young end
okay yeah and i think it helped a lot
and then suddenly
i started working harder i started
just liking school more doing better and
then
i did really well in high school so got
into harvard how well um
how well how well like what 4.0 4.1 i
mean yeah pretty close i think yeah you
know i graduated [ __ ]
laude good high school and and and i
just ended up you know i i don't think i
got any b's i th i did really well um
were you into school or how did you how
did you do so well and what makes you go
from being
a bad student like you said not my words
but like a bad student until just like
an incredible student in one year
yeah i'm not sure i i feel like
i think i just started liking
school more right
i like the structure of school and that
kind of stuff most people don't like
school yeah i kind of enjoyed it um i
might even go back to business school in
september
yeah it's weird yeah um but i actually i
bought my cooking studio to film the
videos every you know that i do every
day three minutes away from where i may
go to grad school so i've kind of
planned it all around that i'm not sure
if i will now okay it's weird i like
school i like the structure of it i like
i like learning okay did you have extra
curriculars in high school too because
i'm curious because not very few people
like that what's the acceptance rate to
harvard isn't it like it's under like
five percent right like really really
low last year was two point yeah it's
crazy so what did you have to do in high
school to get into harvard like was it a
good letter you wrote was it an s.a.t
score was it marx was it
extracurriculars i'm just i think it's
the wow factor that's what i always say
yeah i always say
if you want to get into good school now
i mean or top you know a school that has
a crazy low acceptance rate like you
have to have that wow factor
um
at the very least you have to have
something that makes them wanna take you
into the
the uh
the room for an interview that's the
hard thing to get now right as an
interview in the first place because
there's so many kids and i think
part of my wow factor was um
was just the whole thing with food
because i was already starting to work
in restaurants and i loved i loved
cooking and i love food and i feel like
i mean at least not many guys are into
that sort of thing um at least not in
middle school in high school i remember
get got made fun of if i ever really
talked about liking the cook in middle
school
um
it becomes maybe more socially
acceptable in high school for for a dude
to love cooking but but i feel like
i don't know i just feel like i feel
like i i had enough hopefully enough of
that wow factor to get the interview and
then it just kind of went from there so
it worked out um what happened in the
interview did you just cook up like a
mean burger and like
that's the craziest part i remember my
harvard interview i went in i was all
prepared i had all the questions ready
they asked you for a joke i had a joke
ready they asked you for a joke no so so
i was like what's the joke i i looked at
every site getting ready for you know an
interview and i was told like have a
joke ready because they might ask you
that you can't tell the inappropriate
jokes that are the most the ones that i
know right and so
and so i had a joke ready i had
everything ready and then for 45 minutes
we just talked about my
job at this restaurant because it
happened to be the admissions officer's
favorite restaurant can we hear the joke
yeah i think we're getting to it what
joke did you prepare yeah yeah i'm
curious about that oh the harvard joke
oh man i think it was
i think it was one that my dad used to
tell it might have been um
if you're american when you walk into
the room and you're american when you
walk out of the room bathroom what are
you when you're in the bathroom
american european
[Laughter]
wow that's hilarious that admissions
would request a joke from you yeah well
i don't like the mood yeah i don't know
but
i just remember i
part of it was for sure i mean a little
lucky that she just loved this
restaurant but it was my first
restaurant job and she was like when i
said it i remember her just saying
that's my husband my husband and i drive
there you know it's a 45 minute hour
drive from from harvard and they had
driven there all the time for dinner so
i was like this is perfect and we just
talked about it the whole the whole meal
i was like don't go on a tuesday because
the ingredients won't be fresh that day
it's when they get all the new shipments
in it's like going on wednesday through
saturday whatever gave her all the tips
she loved it it was that at that
restaurant did you have like a cook
position or were you like a management
position no i mean i knew my place i i
i was sort of the bottom of the totem
pole restaurants are like that right
where you have that chef you have the
hierarchy a little bit it was a fancy
restaurant it was a nice restaurant it
wasn't necessarily yeah it was a nice
restaurant um
and i
would grab them the broom and sweep the
floor if i ever didn't know what to do
just so i wasn't in the way and i was
actually helping
and then they would let me do stuff once
in a while and
um and i i was just learning a ton but
again i was sort of an apprentice i
guess i was i was in the kitchen though
and they let me sort of do more as they
trusted me more you know yeah was
harvard your number one choice for
schools
well this is a totally kind of separate
side of my whole story but i
i grew up in rhode island
and um and everyone there
uh it's all in the water rhode island if
you've ever been it's it's all in the
water and so
i played a bunch of different sports i
didn't know what i wanted to do
and then
i have
ironically my dad is a foot
foot doctor
and i have the worst feet and ankles
ever really flat feet so i had to stop
playing all those sports yeah it's the
worst right
and i just and mine get really painful i
can't i can't walk or run for longer
than i don't know half an hour without
it starting to really get painful now
and so
i my dad told me that i should sort of
be careful and stop playing all these
running sports that kind of stuff and so
i
i stopped doing that and i and i sailed
which is what a lot of people from rhode
island do again it's all in the water
and just everybody does that whether
it's for
you know athletic purposes or for fun
everyone sales so i did that and that
helped too
so i was i was pretty good at that okay
yeah it's harvard have a sailing team i
feel like they yeah yeah okay so i was
recruited there too got it which helped
yes helped a lot for sure did you see
that that thing about the admissions
scandal i did yeah and and they had like
the pictures of the boats and stuff i
was like oh my god people are going to
think i'm part of that
brutal yeah yeah for those that don't
know it basically parents were paying
the the coaches yeah to bribe their way
in to say like hey we're recruiting
these people for let's say the row team
yeah like the crew team and they take
pictures
of their son or daughter right through
in a swimming pool and photoshop it yeah
have you seen this no oh jack you have
to see it it's called mind blowing i
forget no but you know it's the craziest
part
so i had interviewed with the coaches
sanford who's the main guy in that whole
thing he's in that movie yeah his name's
john
and i interviewed with them i talked to
stanford and so
so and i actually knew some of the kids
on that team
so
i mean he's the main guy so people that
had never sailed before ever sailed or
rowing or water polo they would just
take a picture
with a water polo cap on and a ball in
their hand and and the parents would
send it to the coach there was some guy
that ran the whole operation yeah
apparently the kids were not aware of
this the parents would just do this
behind the kids back
and they're joking yeah how would the
kids not be aware of that
getting recruited to be on a water bowl
team and never having played in your
life well no no they'd go to the school
and they'd never play water polo
the kids probably didn't even know half
the time yes the kids weren't aware of
this they just said go meet with this
person say you're interested in this and
they'll get you in
the kids might have know what i'm saying
yeah the kids i mean when they go to
school they didn't do one water right
right right
yeah not crazy that is very crazy but
first i want to thank our sponsor ftx
alex graham says i should be investing
in crypto but i can't because the fees
are just so absurdly high i just don't
know what to do ah jack just use ftx you
can buy and sell krypton nfts with
absolutely no fees whatsoever ftx is
trusted by over 6 million people to buy
sell and keep track of all their
favorite cryptocurrencies with ftx you
can set up reoccurring buys allowing you
to invest your money directly from your
bank account automatically every single
month other crypto exchanges charge fees
every time you have a crypto transaction
or withdraw money with ftx every crypto
transaction you make is completely free
and with every trade over ten dollars
you can earn free crypto so instead of
paying fees to invest you can get paid
and the ftx app gives you important news
updates and news feeds directly from top
crypto projects and they even offer a
crypto friendly debit card allowing you
to spend crypto at millions of merchants
worldwide you can use the ftx app to buy
your favorite nfts with no gas fees
supporting both ethereum and solana
blockchains so start trading crypto and
nfts with no fees today by downloading
the ftx app down below in the
description guys the link is down below
in the description to start trading
crypto and nfts with no fees using ftx
thank you so much ftx and back to the
podcast yeah and they were paying
hundreds of thousands of dollars i mean
it's a big if you're at that point why
are you i just don't understand why
would you pay instead of just giving the
money to your kids
like to be amongst your friends oh yeah
yeah yeah johnny's in stanford this year
yes because when you have that sort of
like success and money yeah
and everyone else has that what else can
you brag about it's your kid going to
harvard stanford and ivy league
getting in
guess what stacey down the street their
daughter went to cal state northridge
stacey paid her daughter down there
so you know
that's what i think it i think it's just
stupid kind of crazy yeah yeah i would
rather just take the money frankly i
agree but no so so that helped too so i
had a nice sort of okay um it's a good
foundation i ran the community service
program in my high school i was super
into that stuff i um i i was on the
sailing team i was the captain i
and i did really well with that and then
i i had the good academics so that stuff
together i think wow
and how did you do in harvard i imagine
that just success continued so i did
well but funnily enough i left harvard
senior year for three and a half months
for masterchef
and i still graduated that year so i did
not get delayed at all by that um
but they gave me some bad grades with
that so i was actually .02 away from
graduating with the high owners there
with the same kumarata i don't know
maybe as a master chef but it was worth
does that bother you at all that you
didn't get yeah point zero two come on
did they not did you not talk to the
teacher and say hey just bump this up i
mean come on right to say come on i mean
i think they gave me pretty fair grades
for the fact that i was gone that long
but you know i gotta i got enough i got
enough i got a couple c c pluses type
things yeah yeah a couple b's b minuses
i mean i was gone i wasn't even in class
so
but i did get an a solid a at a class at
harvard and i never once showed up to
the lecture hall that's kind of a nice
like class is that
i don't remember the name but it was one
of those general education classes did
you take tests online or something yeah
the the the homework and the problems
that are all online and so i
i i was proud of that
wow that's pretty cool
and to get on masterchef was there like
an application process or why you
specifically how did you get on the show
yeah uh
the audition was five minutes from
harvard so i just made a ravioli and i
showed up and then
i don't know a couple months later we
had interviews and other stuff after
that a couple months later i was
catching a flight to l.a and then i
stayed for three and a half months so i
could have been sent home at any time if
i got kicked off
but i
you know i went all the way to the end
and and what is there where did the love
for cooking start you mentioned like
middle school you're into [ __ ] was it
like a parent that was into this and you
kind of picked up from that was it a
good restaurant you went to
my
family for sure is a good you know
that's a good way people get into really
anything um and so
we had i had a nice i have a nice kind
of well-rounded family background we
have i have a persian grandfather i had
um italian grandparents italian
great-grandparents people from germany
the uk i mean my aunt is indian pretty
much everywhere which is pretty cool and
so in that sense you're having different
family gatherings throughout the year
your food from everywhere and so that's
one good way right that
i picked up different things from food
in in that front and then
and then
i don't know maybe it was a thing where
i just liked eating good food and so to
know how to make it myself was a lot
nicer than i mean even for a kid making
a killer grilled cheese
most kids can't do it
um but if you can learn how to do you
can make yourself grilled cheese
whenever you want you know it's kind of
simple to think about but
i mean who doesn't want grilled cheese
or chicken nuggets or something like
that i still have chicken nuggets every
day basically
so it's like every day i think i do yeah
do you make them yourself no i just put
them in the
dino nuggets or that's what i imagine
really yeah
they're good though huh i love nuggets
yeah and i i get creative with the
sauces all mixed together some barbecue
sauce some honey some ketchup some mayo
that's funny as a kid i thought it was
so clever i mixed ketchup and mustard
together
and i called it uh ketchup
and i thought it was like invented i
like that cactured yeah it's not an
[Laughter]
oh man anyway i thought it was so cool
that i'd make this like orange sauce yes
that was mine
not like yeah so what was your what was
the first thing you started cooking was
it grilled cheese
no i think it was dessert because i had
a huge sweet tooth as a kid and and
funny funnily enough i never ordered
shirts anymore i don't like desserts i
like candy and stuff i have a bit of a
sweet tooth still i'm not a big dessert
guy but that's what i started off making
it was a lot of um the first thing i
ever remember making was a lemon
meringue pie which is kind of a hard
thing to make actually but
but i i was really clever i couldn't ask
my mom for candy i couldn't ask her for
sweets but i could ask her to get me all
the ingredients for making a baked good
that i would share with the family so i
would eat sugar just out of the bag
after i'd give her these ingredient
lists i would just eat it out of the
cupboard um
and then i would use it to make the
recipe but i would just eat the sugar it
was actually pretty clever um and so i
think
you know i got in the baking baking side
of things and i started helping at big
family gatherings christmas and you know
the holidays and and after that um
it just kind of kept spinning into
something i did more and more so tell us
about this ravioli that you made ta for
the top chef for yeah for um
so
it was a shrimp and chive i think it was
a shrimp and chive ravioli and um
it was good it was it was fine
the the auditions are weird you show up
with a ton of people and there's some
there's some characters there i mean you
see a big line of people i showed up
early there's a line of a couple hundred
people by you know ten minutes after
they open up it's out they're always at
hotels
and um and you bring a dish and then you
have a couple minutes to assemble it
and then they come around and taste it
obviously you know gordon ramsay's not
there yeah but his producers are and he
has his culinary team there and all this
stuff but
kind of chaos but it was good it was
just a little i just figured i'd make
some pasta and um
and then my audition dish was a little
bit more creative it was a it was a
raviol ravioli again um which of course
is italian and then it had a
persian filling so i feel like i'm
i mostly identify with being sort of
persian italian that's the two sides
that i feel like i took most culinary
inspiration from so it's the perfect
combo i'm wondering if 200 plus people
are making dishes for these taste
testers wouldn't you think they get
really full and like by the end they're
like the food stops tasting so good
because like is that an issue or they do
that i mean there's thousands of people
at the at each each call each open call
so and they have to taste all that food
so i'm sure they take tiny bites of it
they have a lot of people they never
spit it out like after
i
i'm sure
yeah okay i'm sure they do yeah yeah i
mean because some of this stuff is also
kind of nasty
you know i mean you wouldn't want to eat
all that stuff no you don't know where
it's coming from and it was about the
citizens people's houses people brought
their own food oh yeah no people are
that's what i'm saying like imagine they
bake that with it's like old ingredients
oh so you made it at your house and then
you bring it there it's a little
disgusting yeah
but wow that's how it works i don't know
if still like that maybe after covert
it's not like that anymore it would be
my guess that's incredible i'd be
worried that like some somebody could
like put something in there that yeah no
seriously it's a little sketchy yeah and
how much do they consider the big
picture instead of just the food itself
like they see you you know you're a tall
attractive guy like you know he'll look
good on camera you know how much they
consider that instead of just the dish
itself do you think it's a good question
i feel like all those reality shows they
just you know who knows really what the
formula is right but but at the end of
the day you have to expect they're
probably looking for a college kid in
there somewhere yeah and so
um
so as long as i feel like you can hit
the basic criteria of okay he can he can
cook enough to to be on the show he's
got the he can he can hold a
conversation or he can be good for tv
whatever then i feel like you can get
fast the first round but then there's a
lot of stuff there's i mean i feel like
they do background checks and there's
like all sorts of evaluations and it's
just a while i remember the process was
months and months yeah i was doing it
while i was just doing my regular school
stuff and then you know every couple
weeks i'd get an email update
so you got to show up at this place or
have a phone call whatever and then
there would be quiet and then you know
eventually there's that they said okay
you're going to fly out but first i want
to thank our sponsor ladder i don't have
a wife or a fiance or a girlfriend but
if i did i would want to help protect
them from any huge financial burden if
something bad were to ever happen and
with term coverage being so affordable
it really doesn't make sense not to a
healthy 35 year old man can get his
family a million dollars in coverage for
only 35
a month you can get ladders easy to
apply for and affordable life insurance
coverage from the comfort of your own
home in just a few minutes just sign up
from your phone or laptop and ladder
smart algorithms will let you know
instantly if you're approved there are
no hidden fees and you can cancel
anytime you want and if you change your
mind within the first 30 days you can
get a full refund life insurance only
gets pricier as you age so now is the
perfect time to cross it off your list
so check out ladderlife.com
iced coffee today to get your free quote
that's ladder l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
iced coffee ladderlife.com iced coffee
thank you so much ladder and back to the
podcast were you already doing tick tock
at the time of master chef so tick tock
came after master chef i didn't even
know what tick tock was actually i had
no idea i joined tick tock
kind of early on during the first big
cove wave and lockdown
um
so yeah i didn't even know what it was i
never even heard of it and did your did
you tell your family and friends about
the master chef thing or did they you're
not allowed to technically you're not
supposed to really tell anybody is the
rules right so
of course you can tell your fan your
immediate family but you're not supposed
to tell anybody else ironically i didn't
even tell any of my teachers at school i
just left it's kind of a weird thing to
do but i just left and but you don't get
any technology or anything like that
there so it's kind of difficult you
don't get technology no you just get you
get a phone call every a couple minutes
for a phone call like every sunday but
that's it yeah one phone call every
second
that's all public info i think yes wait
i don't unders so you fly to l.a do they
lock you up in some yeah you're in a
hotel yeah
and you can't leave i think this is
pretty common for for you know reality
all these shows so it's like you are
closed off from the world yeah and you
can't leave
i mean not unless someone's with you
once in a while we took like a little
trip up the road to get something but no
you're your hotel
yeah do they feed you you have your own
room and everything was it a luxurious
experience or was it like i mean it's
just perfectly so do you
have internet i mean no well no you
don't have a phone you don't have to
understand why why can't you order and
like check emails not like that no no no
you can't do anything like that why
can't it's so easy for someone to go
ahead and just give spoilers or get paid
by something i guess so
yeah
right but you would think that they
would just monitor your internet
activity right maybe maybe yeah
yeah i know i mean it would just be so
hard yeah it starts with 80 people or
something yeah okay and did you were you
able to talk with the other people or
would you yeah you could talk and stuff
so you could go and like knock on your
neighbors you know
well no because you didn't have your own
room key so you can't really leave your
like room yeah that sounds like
imprisonment no it's a part of the show
jack no because you're not in the hotel
that much you're at this you're on the
set oh okay the whole day like five a.m
until
night so wow yeah it's a long day every
day you are going to home and you're
going to bed
you're tired wow yeah and when you eat
crazy they provide you food or do you
cook in your kitchen and practice no no
they provide you food you don't get to
practice how do they know throughout the
rounds that you're not just like
microwaving tattooed chef and bringing
that to them and they're like wow that's
so good oh between the cookie yeah
is there before they select you is there
something where they have you cook the
food in front of them
oh before you get there yeah yeah
there's there's a lot of layers to get
to the final okay so the first day yeah
how was it to go three months without
like a connection to the outside world
was super nice would you read a lot how
would you spend your time i mean
i i i pretty much mean it when i say we
were on set and filming and doing all
that stuff and then the second you got
home you're so tired that you were out
for three months though yeah it was
really nice and and waking up at waking
up at 4 or 4 30. i felt really good and
you could go work out you do that stuff
and and waking up at 4 or 4 30 it
doesn't it's not bad after a while it's
nice and quiet in the morning you're
used to it were you the only one getting
up that early or was everyone everybody
had everyone yeah okay yeah everybody
had to because the boss would leave at
five or something so or six or whatever
it was each day changed a little bit but
it was nice it was actually really nice
yeah that's pretty crazy so i'm assuming
you know once you got third place or
whatever you got out
you went back to real life did you like
check your instagram and all of a sudden
your instagram crazy yeah really and
like you you maybe you got recognized or
something or you know classmates saw you
my assumption is that all of this is
filmed in advance and then they oh
god yeah yeah but tell us about your
first day there yeah
uh
masterchef yeah
like what do they have you do well the
first day
the first day was
the first day was uh just meeting all
the judges and and i think just uh a lot
of people's families were out there
and um
and you know they're just getting you
all excited and all that stuff
and
and then
after that it was just a blur i mean
people would get eliminated you'd say
bye it was it was sad if you were really
good friends with the people and and um
and then
it just whipped all the way through and
then
for the end we got to go to london with
with gordon
which was really fun we flew to london
with the top four or six people which
was great that was crazy and then um
yeah and then suddenly like sort of like
you said just it's not my fingers i was
back in my dorm
what was it like meeting gordon ramsay
what was the first experience meeting
him he
is really nice i i only ever have good
things to say about him i really do i'm
not just saying that um
he's really nice he
is
intense and passionate and but he's
really nice he is
um
just a sort of a normal goofy dude when
you actually meet him and talk to him
yeah but
again it's so much of it it's just a
blur and then did he ever yell at you oh
yeah yeah
was it scary there was one day that i
was actually i don't know if scared is
the right word but he stopped everything
to yell at me
um what was the story the filming and
the clocks and are you serious wait wait
so the cameras were all i think i think
i just got maybe caught him at a wrong
time or something and i didn't hear him
because i was really in the zone it was
towards the end
and
and all of a sudden i just hear like
some swearing and yelling and he's
looking at me and i get really
embarrassed like my face will like flush
red sometimes like i'm very shy i'm kind
of you know and i sort of froze
and he basically was just sort of he was
just upset he
he had wanted everyone's attention or
something to something had gone wrong he
wanted to tell everyone and brief
everyone and i just didn't hear i was
just cooking i was running around yeah
and then he just snapped at me so that
was pretty scary because he stopped
everything he snapped at you because you
weren't like paying attention to yeah it
wasn't really yeah yeah yeah it wasn't
he wasn't being meaningless why would he
stop the cameras for that you would
think that that's like something went
wrong or something i don't know like
that never happened so he does have a
little bit of a temper sometimes but
it's just passive it's definitely
intense yeah i mean you you don't want
to mess with them
but how much of that is for the camera
because i would imagine it's like if
cameras weren't rolling he'd be like so
nice and then
did this tastes like i can't just i'm
not even going to try this it's a good
accent
no he was very playful and
seriously kind of silly when the cameras
are off uh from what i remember and
and also
i i still remember a day where it was
really cold it was really cold out we
were doing some shoot at a castle and i
i was freezing because the i was wearing
some like collared shirt and nothing
else and everyone else had jackets on
and they dress you so like you know i
didn't get the shoes i was wearing and
then
and then i remember he ran up behind me
with a jacket and like kind of like bear
hugged me with a jacket or something
like that he's like he he yelled at
someone for the fact that i was like so
cold and shivering he's like why isn't
he wearing this and then he ran up
behind me himself and i was like boom so
he was just a goofy like okay like he
was a goofy guy he wasn't he's he's cool
and now like since you've blown up and
everything you're doing collabs and
stuff with him how does that feel
like well hold on jack we're skipping is
skipping it doesn't have to go
chronological it doesn't i want to know
what it was like what your what your
first thoughts were when you got
eliminated at being third oh my first
thoughts yeah what what do you think you
could have done better what led to that
and uh what was like the first reaction
because to get third i mean there's got
to be a point in you where like i have a
chance at winning this yeah i mean of
course at the end you're trying to sort
of figure out it's like
where do i stand you're always trying to
look at the judges and see what's on
their faces this is scary and we had a
lot of friends and family there we got
to fly our whole family and a bunch of
our i had a bunch of my best friends
from college that kind of stuff out
there watching live at the end
um
but i just remember sort of i i kept my
cool i was i might be i've been in a
little bit of shock too because it was
just sort of a you know
it's
it's a it's even just i felt bad that i
had my friends and family fly all the
way out for like this finale and then i
got last in the finale you know what i
mean yeah i got third but there's only
three people competing in this whole big
thing at the end so i i don't know that
was my first thing i was like i feel so
bad everyone's here to watch me and then
i just i just didn't i lost but you know
it was it was um
it was all good no it all worked out for
the best so
yeah i wasn't too i wasn't too upset how
many job offers you get after that
i don't even know i mean for anyone in
that position you get just an influx of
messages whether it's from people that
you know really well you know people
that you don't really know that well but
that have your contact and just want to
say congratulations or reach out and
then there's just the whole you know i
was getting tons of stuff on even
linkedin and all this stuff i mean
so
you know
i feel like i got a lot of random stuff
like the job offers to go to some
go to some
island in the bahamas and run the food
program for a hotel or something like
night probably decent job offers yeah
but uh yeah and interestingly enough um
right out of college i was i was
supposed to accept the full-time job at
mcdonald's corporate and
which is which is i was basically going
to be an undercover food inspector
speaking of chicken nuggets
would have gotten eat chicken nuggets
every day multiple times a day wait i'm
curious how much do they pay because it
seems like to be like almonds yeah a
harvard graduate like
minimum you got to be making like 120k
you're like
right off the go i think so no no no no
i mean
it
it's
you'd be surprised even how many kids
out of harvard that just didn't have a
job even when we graduated yeah yeah
is that because their expectations are
their standards are high for their jobs
because i feel like it's like
maybe a little bit but at the same time
i mean
i know i i mean of course everyone
thinks of harvard as this you know it's
like the pinnacle of of schools or
whatever but doesn't i mean it doesn't
really matter where you go if you have
some sort of passion and you and you do
well in college and whatever um
so so yeah i knew i mean i you'd be
really surprised how many kids come at
harvard with no job wow yeah
so how much do undercover food
inspectors make i think the whole i mean
if i had to guess the whole deal was
probably around six figures like 100k
but it that that but that that would be
including like a car and all this
different stuff
what made you accept that offer be like
that's the offer i want to take
i i don't know
i i mean
the chicken nuggets
no
i feel like
i feel like i
wanted to do something with food and
want to do something with business and
that was you know i got to talk to the
franchise franchise owners right the
franchise and and and i think the the
people that own you know mcdonald's
locations they often own let's say 15 or
10 right so these are
serious business people who have a huge
operation going on and they want to know
how to make their franchisees better so
my job would have been to go unrecover
inspect outside inside inspect the food
the people how nice they are to me
whatever
and then
and then
at the end of the month or you know
however long
periods in between i forget report back
to the franchise owners and talk to them
about how how everything was and so it's
actually a really cool job and i was
gonna go to long beach california and i
was gonna make my own schedule a little
bit i just had a quota each month i
think i was gonna surf i was gonna you
know hang out
so it's not a nine to five though is it
like you just go whenever you want no it
was a really cool job i was actually
really excited for it and i kept in
touch with the recruiter for a while
because i was like i'm really sorry but
i have this you know i did a tv show
things are all over the place right now
so i was keeping very transparent with
her about the situation and then
eventually i was like she was like can
we really she asked can we release the
spot and i said yeah so so when you say
there's a quota is there like you have
to visit
50 mcdonald's in this quarter
and it's up to you when you visit them
yeah and then what do you do you just go
in i'm sure you have a checklist of
items you can check the bathroom order
this see the quality
exactly okay yeah that's it and who
hired you was it mcdonald's or was it
the franchise owners no mcdonald's yeah
so you it would be in this section of
mcdonald's yeah you would be leaving
this like region of mcdonald's it was
the first time they were ever doing this
program wow which was really cool 20 000
kids applied supposedly for 20 spots no
super hard to get position harder to get
into than harvard maybe yeah
which is funny but so no really great
job
uh
super nice people at the company that's
why i picked it because i looked at some
others
uh and and i liked the people at
mcdonald's a lot i really really liked
them all and so you know didn't work out
but maybe maybe someday how would they
not recognize you though the employees
if you're continuing to like frequent
the exact same you know 15 or so
mcdonald's i
well i don't know i think your checklist
is pretty big you kind of venture out a
little bit not only that but you think
do you think the employees remember
someone who comes in once every five
months yeah probably gonna stay
undercover too yeah maybe word gets out
that you're the guy you know her glasses
i think even the tv show would make you
less likely to be suspected because like
he wouldn't be under like look at him he
wouldn't be take this job yeah what are
you trying to say about that job i'm
just saying it's like
he's
you know i don't know he's coming in
eating a hamburger
it's not like for any other purpose
besides like eating a burger did you
need like uh to prove to them that you
have a refined palate or something for
that position no
i'm it's not about that i'm sure it's
like did they put lettuce on this are
there three pickles on this is the
bathroom yeah oh yeah is the bathroom
clean is the outside trash area got it
uh you know the seating area cleaned
yeah i know mcdonald's is really
stringent for their franchise owners and
the franchise owners i think because i
looked into this a long time ago because
i wanted to open up a franchise briefly
not a mcdonald's just a franchise in
general mcdonald's was one of the
toughest ones to get
no it was actually chick-fil-a was the
toughest one yeah and then mcdonald's
yeah but yeah the mcdonald's ones on
average i think each owner owns
the average owners like three to four
mcdonald's yeah and you have to keep a
million dollars liquid cash per business
just
to weather whatever you know volatility
they have in terms of like you know
sales and whatnot it's crazy but yeah
but and and i think for mcdonald's they
require some sort of prior
restaurant or business ownership
experience of another franchise so i
don't think you could just be a
franchise owner for mcdonald's i think
you have to
operate something else first before you
do a mcdonald's because you got to think
if you go to one mcdonald's you kind of
assume it's the same as all of them
right right so one bad owner is like i i
don't like mcdonald's anymore it affects
all of them it's crazy they're strict
yeah
didn't work out yeah
and the reason why it didn't work out is
because you started doing tick tocks and
stuff like that and then that whole
i started just getting different
opportunities for a master chef and then
you know and then tick tock came a
little bit later but i just what were
some of the opportunities that started
popping up yeah they weren't they
weren't big um
nothing nothing was big but
you know i did a i did a collab with
some protein bar type company
made a new bar with them it did really
well whatever um you know the masterchef
story can only carry you for so long
though you know yeah so tick tock kind
of came in after that what were the
first videos that you were making on tik
tok um the first ones were actually just
uh weirdly of my hamster and we were
feeding my hamster stuff which is a
little strange did you make the food
yeah you did it was like luxurious like
make the hamster you know a beautiful
mini plate of pancakes we bought all
this mini doll no silverware yeah kind
of fun and they actually were doing well
they were getting a couple million views
or something like that and which is kind
of insane right for watching a hamster
eat
and i still have a few up on my tick
tock just for old time's sake they're
back down there you know that's fun kind
of fun and then how did that evolve
though
i don't know i
i
i've i've said this a few times uh the
first video that that that did well on
tick tock that really made me click and
after that day i filmed every single day
the whole day just for
you know i pretty much still film every
day now so
um hasn't really stopped i guess now
that i think about it but it was a cacao
pod video it was chocolate and i made a
chocolate bar from a cacao pod people
were freaking out it looks all
alien-like and you know and so i made
that
and i think people just
had never seen that before everyone
likes chocolate but no one knew where
the
where the
chocolate came from in the first place
because i mean most people you don't
even think about that you just make some
more and you don't think about it but
so that that did really well and then i
just dove into making crazy videos and
and showing people new crazy things and
you know so that was the first food one
i made i don't know why i made it but i
did and then it had about almost two
million views in like an hour and i was
like what is going on and so after that
you know i took take talk really
seriously do you think that your master
chef presence helped out with your tick
tock growth at all or do you think they
were unrelated
maybe at the start i mean people people
at the start may have recognized me but
again
i mean
what three million people i think watch
an episode each episode of masterchef so
in the big picture of things it's not a
crazy amount when i'm getting almost
that many views on these videos to begin
with right so you grow out of that
pretty quickly and then
um and then i just had to figure out
what my kind of knit what my narrative
was going to be and what about tick tock
like did you study different growth
strategies how you can properly time and
structure each video would you like talk
with other creators to get ideas on how
to grow or did you just kind of do it on
your own and figure out what was best
for you i'm i'm super i'm super
collaborative in that sense so i talked
to a lot of creators and but but i i did
spend a lot of time on my own
trying to figure it out i even
one of my good friends and i built out a
computer program that we could input all
these different sort of things so if i
was going to make a video on making a
nice coffee i could put in the different
things of the so like
did i spank any food in this video the
answer would be no for this one right
did i do this no um is it over 15
seconds yes and we could put it all out
and before i posted the video we
actually started getting a pretty good
sense of how the video was gonna do so
that helped me learn a lot too actually
we just built out this whole thing where
we could kind of plug in you know plug
in different things and that actually
helped to to learn a lot about okay this
works well this doesn't work well they
should be kind of this length um
so that worked first and then after that
i just you know
to know tick tock well i think you you
have to use it a lot so i was using a
lot i now don't have tic tac or
instagram my phone anymore i deleted
those because i was spending too much
time and i was like all right i gotta
i gotta get rid of them or i'm just
gonna keep going on them until one wait
wait a second okay so you deleted tick
tock um
how many followers do you have on tick
tock
about eight and a half million
and you deleted tick-tock just you post
on tick tock anymore we post i mean a
couple times a week but i oh but you
deleted your personal account like on my
browsing it's not on my phone so you
send it to someone or do you have like a
phone or something
someone posts from there but but i just
was spending too much time yeah i find
it so interesting how bad tiktok is for
your mind well i've started going on to
those videos and no it's funny it's like
how bad it is for your mind and then
meanwhile i'm like i'm going to have
this youtube rabbit hole of how bad
tick-tock is for you people are spending
all of their time on tick-tock well i'm
spending even more time on youtube
but no no but i i do think at least
youtube i feel like i'm learning
something on youtube where i go into it
and i'm like i come out of it better i
learned something new today i i expanded
my mind a little bit but every time i'm
on tick tock
it feels like
my brain just like kind of
shrinks a little bit i yeah i feel like
and yeah when you start to see just the
differences between
what locations show like what on tick
tock and how like i hate to say like how
dumb
yeah tick tock is here
but it's like the the most mindless
videos that are addictive to watch and
it's incredible how fast time goes when
you're on tik tok and just that that
it's it's that that swiping motion that
keeps you that keeps you there uh and
that that burst of just like here's 15
seconds 15 seconds what's next what's
that it reminds me and it's been
compared to uh the same
uh the same transmitters in your brain
as if you're gambling at a slot machine
just it's a chip
it's that reward system it's insane and
it's like i'm curious what that's gonna
do to like a child's mind who's growing
yeah he's probably between the ages of
like six and
eighteen who's like still developing but
they spend two hours a day on tick tock
what is their attention span gonna be
like i mean it's just i think it's not
good it's not good
i mean people's attention spans are
getting so low in fact that that we've
started um
i i've started clipping together all the
clips in my video
and then
uh trimming them a little bit shorter
than they normally would so that i'm
almost maybe cutting myself off
from an audio standpoint and then we'll
extend the audio clips over each other
so that we're and that's just a i mean
that's crazy that you know that that
actually changes
yeah i've watched your recent videos and
i've seen just how fast it's like every
few seconds change changes change change
few seconds man it's like splits yeah
yeah but like you'll say like hey guys
what you know whatever and it's like
like there's another angle or like
it's crazy it's not
yeah i mean i've watched my even my own
tick tock evolve over time to keep up
with how fast-paced everything is
yeah it's just kind of how it is now and
you gotta just either you have someone's
attention or you don't it's gone and
they're gone yeah part of me wonders if
it's because there's so many more people
right now creating content that to keep
you on the platform longer they have to
show you the best of the best of the
best and because there's so many people
feeding into that it's just it's
optimized for just whatever gets your
attention the fastest for the longest
yeah it's becoming very oversaturated
that's why i'm working really hard right
now and i'm if i can still keep getting
decently performing videos right if
then then i might as well keep pushing
on it um even though i'm really not
taking any days off from filming but you
know when it slows down a little i'll
i'll take a breather yeah that's my
that's my i like that yeah i like that i
have a very similar uh philosophy on
things oh no that's good to hear isn't
it chad it's really nice to hear that
we always have a disagreement we have
some people on the podcast who are very
much like work all the time but then we
get just as many people on there who are
like no you don't need to do that
outsource it delegate outsource are you
an outsource are you an outsourced
mindset kind of guy i i look here's the
thing people think it's just black and
white okay it's a spectrum i would say i
lean more on the side of outsourcing
things that you don't need to do
yourself
and graham is very much so he does
everything himself yeah so
i can't outsource the you know i can't
have some guy stand in for the videos
you know so at the end of the day it's
like i know i'm going to have to keep
filming if i want to keep putting them
out yeah right at such a high frequency
when you start making youtube videos
um only only about a year ago probably
no yeah no i
really i grew we were really quickly on
youtube yeah but i think some of that or
a lot of that is to do with your shorts
that you've been posting on youtube and
we had months where we grew up seven
hundred thousand subs in one month which
is just insane yeah because you have a
few videos the shorts that are like 40
million views 30 million views yeah so
you have to think on 30 million views
you're probably getting about 300 000
subscribers probably 100 to 500 000
subscribers depending on the video
you're right yeah i i know the exact
number what what is the exact do you
know this on my 45 million view video
we've gained 187 000 subscribers which
is yeah almost 200k so you're right on
the sweet spot um
which is crazy
it's insane from one video gosh yeah and
how have you been able to properly
monetize all of your different like
audiences on all these different
platforms what have you found to be the
best the worst and also the crossover
from tiktok to youtube did you notice
that there was crossover or did you have
to grow a completely separate audience
on youtube what jack is trying to ask is
how much money do you make from this
platform you could have just
that's not what i'm trying to ask
no sure yeah you can answer that i think
um interestingly enough i think
i think if anyone were to ask me the
question of what's kind of the most
important platform i have i would say
tick tock but i have made virtually no
money on tick tock in fact
i would almost push to say that i've
lost money on tick tock just you know i
buy one parmesan cheese wheel and there
goes three grand right so this is a
video that macy sent me a few months ago
uh this is before we even connected she
said look at this it's a cheese wheel
it's all this money it's a good
investment good buy cheese
could you explain this really quick
she's right yeah if you were to buy that
wheel and you break it up into smaller
pieces you'd be very surprised that
would last you years that'll last you
many years right um if it's just you
know let's say two people it's a lot of
cheese but
but
uh there is something special about
cracking into a palm wheel yeah it's fun
it's fun i think i did it for the first
time did it for the first time crack my
first farm wheel uh what was that like
uh i do use protection
goggles in case uh you are using some
sharp knives yeah right um i think i did
it for the first time a little over a
year ago when i was trying to continue
just having the the that wow factor in
the videos and it was a great way to do
some you know something like that
because
uh it was a great way to get that wow
factor because everyone loves
everyone loves cheese wheel pasta and so
i just figured i'll
i'll i'll do it on tick tock and
yeah so why is tick tock the most
important even though it makes you the
no money i just think it's such a
powerful platform
the way that the algorithm works the way
that frankly the way that i feel like i
understand it um
you can reach so many people so fast
and
you know you can't post it you can't
post it you know you know better than
anyone you can't post a video on youtube
and have
have a couple million views in an hour
there's just no way i mean
that that that would be that's that's
basically impossible on youtube at least
it is now as far as i know but tick tock
you can do it tick tock is is you can
reach so many people so fast but again i
think if if you really boil down the
hours i'm probably working for less than
ten dollars an hour on tick tock
it's crazy right so
no but aren't we talking like brand
deals and stuff like that too like once
in a while but the brands are still
learning to talk at least i feel like
yeah for years i've only done a small
number of brand deals yeah do bang
energy everyone's doing it
make a pasta
imagine that just like this really nice
dish
and you have like a wine glass and you
just poor bang energy
i see that everywhere that would be a
great ad though you know it for real
like imagine you're serving like this
really nice lobster dinner with like
caviar
and bang energy yeah
like a romantic dinner with your
girlfriend of like yeah
yeah energy chicken wings anything
really yeah
anything yeah
i think that would be funny it would be
funny i i would like that i would like
that i like that or you like you
incorporate bang energy like you know
sometimes they'll pour like wine into
like the you know the pasta yeah
you cook with it yeah you just cook with
it a lot of creativity five five meals
with bad energy that you could make from
home yeah no that would be good
marketing
anyway
yeah but the crazier the better on tick
tock but youtube i mean you're posting
in an insane amount what is your every
day yeah what does your team look like
right now um
so
the people that are kind of around me in
person every day it's really only it's
really only two people i have my camera
guy that's there often and then but i
film all the tick tocks myself right i
will keep it that way i just like it and
i can stay in the zone yeah i have a you
know an in-person assistant who's
full-time she helps around a lot of
social media super creative so that's
it's awesome because
you know i can have someone to kind of
have it we bounce ideas off each other
and think of some great concepts now for
videos
and then
i would say that the overall team is i
mean it's
you know i don't it's all relative but
it's getting fairly large now you know i
have a i haven't had a head of
operations um i have management through
uta so i've got the agent i've got you
know kind of a team there and then um
and then you know uta under that whole
umbrella you also have you know if you
want to do
stuff with publishing or tv or that
stuff we're having chats with that kind
of stuff now
um and then of course the more standard
stuff like lawyer yeah i have a guy who
just does thumbnails for youtube a
couple editors three editors or so
um it's crazy yeah but you don't need
thumbnails on those things oh so now
you're on my kids you're on my team now
with outsourcing thumbnails
yeah i mean thumbnails on the show as
myself
you have to you have to get people yeah
yeah so so when you make a so when you
come up with a video idea is that you
are you coming up with the idea depends
i mean
sure sometimes yeah i mean literally i'm
in the shower and i think of an idea and
i just hop out and write it on my notes
on my phone i have a long long list in
my phone of just i have separate i have
short form ideas and i have long form
ideas yeah and um
and
yeah and then right off a couple of
ideas you want to hear some yeah some
unreleased ideas yeah let's see
all right yeah also how much do you pay
per thumbnail do you know 30 bucks
really yeah
and then once in a while i give the guy
a bonus and like you don't give him a 50
bonus and he made his his week
he's
um he's from the philippines yeah super
nice yeah the thumbnails aren't i mean
i'm always sure though and i'm like you
don't have to yeah is he you're
full-time
no no so he has multiple clients yeah
okay yeah
yeah i'm curious too for the thumbnails
does he tell you to do a pose or like do
this pose or you just do the pose you're
just doing whatever i just send him
anything and he's pretty good i mean he
does a great job
um you want some tick tock ideas or
youtube ideas let's start with youtube a
little bit of both you want to hear
youtube ideas okay
um let's see
i mean i'm always going through this
list priority ideas i want to do
something in space i want to go to a
coffee farm in costa rica i think that'd
be nice for people because everyone
drinks coffee and yes people don't know
where really really it's from well it's
from bankrollcoffee.com exactly
i wanted to follow a ramen packet
through a prison but i don't think
they're gonna wait what do you mean
ramen well i know it's used as currency
and people cook people make like there's
a there's a cookbook i have at home
that's a like a prison cookbook some guy
i think who was in jail wrote a cookbook
on a bunch of the recipes that they
would make and i just think it'd be a
really interesting thing to like see the
ramen is supposed to be a really big
currency in prison yeah i think that's
essentially apparently people have been
using that as a weapon
yeah you can you can turn it into a yeah
shane so i started watching this channel
it's called soft white underbelly oh i
love that channel yes i love that
channel one picture came up on my so get
this so i i was scrolling my homepage
and i saw this black and white picture i
forget what it was but this person
looked like so sad in this thumbnail
like what is this and i clicked it and
it's this interview
and i started watching me like oh my god
this is a really interesting story it's
like a heartfelt story and then after i
watched that video it's just every other
video now is just like software
underbelly software there and my dude is
posting like every day i'm obsessed with
that me too but i learned from that
there was a guy in jail and he was
telling how a ramen could be used as a
weapon and without going into too much
detail here uh they could basically
shape the ramen to whatever they want it
to be it's bad yeah yeah
yeah so i try to stay away from that
side of it but no i don't know
i i would say maybe pass on that idea
yeah i'll stay away from that for now
crazy ideas on the tick tock front i
mean
i want to make wagyu nuggets
who wouldn't like that love that right
um
uh
i'm definitely gonna make some ostrich
egg pasta soon
um i wanna turn an orange a large orange
you know the the little mandarin orange
cups that are all perfectly smooth
shaved oranges whatever
i want to turn the whole orange into
that you know what i mean i think you
have to use lie
which is
potentially kind of dangerous if you're
breathing it in but i want to do that i
feel like that'd be so cool that would
be a full-size
orange cup okay that makes sense yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you don't like
that idea do you know what i'm doing i
i'm confused you could no you know i
know those things like a little hey you
guys have seen these things before i'm
going to make one something like that
and then you'd go and yeah like with no
pith on it the little oranges that are
and it has the seal on the oranges you
you open yeah yeah it's got the it's in
the juice right yeah i want to turn a
whole big orange like that got it okay
yeah i get it i just seem to be really
cool yeah i like that right you're not
eating any of the strings or any of that
stuff yeah it's a little different okay
it would be interesting if you homemade
a bunch of stuff like an oreo and you
like could actually make an oreo that
because yeah oh this is one last one
i'll give you grilled cheese balls i
want to make grilled cheese balls where
it's the it's a it's a sort of a
ball right and inside is the tip the
tomato soup you injected inside the bowl
i just feel like that'd be delicious
it's like a risotto bar i feel like just
if you why don't you have your own
frozen food line like why not just come
up with a food and sell it that people
could buy and store you don't know
i've got to do this i haven't thought
about it have you met joshua weissman
no no i've never i've never talked to
him actually really never yeah you guys
i feel like are just like
just
we're in the same network yeah and how
have you not spoke because i've spoken
with every other person in like finance
i feel like in food
you would talk to pretty much every
other person in food yeah
i don't know i i don't know not sure i
really don't know if you guys teamed up
on a video that would that would be like
the video that would break i would love
to i think so too i would love to um
yeah i'm not sure i was actually talking
about this morning i made a video with
um with codyco this morning yeah and um
and and we were talking about that
because he's good friends with josh too
yeah never talk to josh i don't know
yeah oh wow what'd you do with cody
we made um
we made chick-fil-a we took chick-fil-a
we threw the buns away we made waffle
waffles for buns mini waffles for the
chicken and then we mixed a bunch of
maple syrup into the chick-fil-a sauce
and put that on there it was really good
wow that was good
yeah i've seen a few of cody's videos
where he's done them with josh is he
into do you must be into cooking yeah i
think he likes to go cool yeah he yeah
um
i think he does yeah we mean it was
pretty tasty i think chick-fil-a might
should start serving it so i'm curious
how does your income break down in terms
of like where you where you make money
youtube tick tock brand deals
yeah so like i said tick tock is you
know close to nothing right um
youtube is a big as a big percentage now
i feel like
i feel like youtube has
got to be
i feel like youtube's got to be 90 of of
the money i make now right maybe tick
tock and
osmo my cell company i don't we don't
take anything from that so that's you
know that's growing on the side but i'm
kind of letting that do its thing and
then yeah we're really talking youtube i
would say a 50 50 split between the
monthly ad revenue and then the brand
deals on there so
it's all it's all youtube so what sort
of brand deals do you get
i have some i actually have cool
partners my favorite uh you know or at
least one of my favorite that i've
worked with over the past year a lot was
was nutella or ferrero as kind of the
bigger brand pretty cool people freaked
out
wait a second so how did they reach out
to you what was like your reaction
oftentimes you think of brand deals as
like oh man like i'm posting this thing
everyone's gonna be mad at me for doing
a brand deal because it ruins you know
it introduces a video
with this people are freaking out
they're like this is my childhood
favorite thing ever still my favorite
thing ever nick's doing a thing with
it's like my dreams have come true
um
but i did something for for kinder first
which is that i think european brand
that they're trying to bring to the us
and then after that i got you know i did
something with um with nutella and they
were doing a big party show with no kid
hungry during the holidays so
we did something really cool there so
that's i mean that's our dream partner
if you could ever have yeah right we
stressed doing that one crazy no i loved
it i made i made nutella churros really
good pumped the middle of the churros
with nutella filled them all up it was
great how long did it take to make i'm
assuming that was a 60 second video um
that was a a youtube like video that's
the whole video but the video is a
sponsor but but the way it is right
right but the the entire video was 60s
it was a short run no no it was a video
yeah it was a long-form youtube video it
probably oh okay it was probably a it
was probably a eight minute eight minute
video video how long did it take to
produce that eight minute video a couple
hours yeah that's it yeah yeah just made
churros
probably two and a half three hours how
do you keep coming up with ideas
um
it's hard i mean i i take full days now
i never used to have to do this because
i had so many ideas but i take full days
now just to strategize and just to
really kind of hone in on the ideas but
and then the other kind of cool thing is
i mean i'm going to start a fully new
channel on just cocktails and i have a
giant list i mean those ideas are even
cooler cocktails yeah i'm worried that
you you combine alcohol with youtube and
they're less likely to
i mean some of the people i see on there
that are doing cocktails are getting
crazy really i've seen what was that the
educated bar fly was the one guy that
i've
that i watched i'm going to call this
channel tipsy nick oh yes okay yeah i've
seen tipsy bartender
um
and but i have i mean i i have a lot of
really fun drinks for that i mean
there's a lot of cool stuff you can do
with alcohol too you can you can take a
you can take i mean you can take a
a a wedge of a you know
whatever orange and you can kind of bend
it backwards and
pump it and it shoots all the sprits and
if you put a lighter under it just does
a huge and there's a lot of cool
cocktail tricks and so do you not worry
though that like alcohol with an
audience who might be maybe younger or
in issues with advertisers or is this
purely just like a new channel totally
new channel totally new audience i i i
think legally i have to make clear at
least on some platforms that it's 21
plus yeah and so this the idea here is
find a totally new audience and and and
you know dive into a more like a new
creative realm i'm excited that's neat
yeah why don't you come out with your
own food i feel like this is like like
really little bagel bites of some sort
like chicken nuggets yeah
that would be a good idea actually
knicks nuggets yeah i mean didn't danny
doesn't come out with didn't danny
duncan come come up with nuggets though
did he i'm not sure
but the problem is then it ties it to
you too much i know i wouldn't call it
i'm actually like a big fan of not
putting my name in the stuff you could
call it kicked in the nuggets
[Music]
uh i would say your osmo assault the
branding is incredible yeah you make it
look so so that was the connection but
noel who does bankroll coffee now for
sale of bankruptcy.com also does your
salt
and who made the connection which i
think is really neat it is pretty cool
yeah yeah how do you reach out to you
i don't remember i think it was just a
cold email
really pretty sure yeah did he uh get
your address and then send a bunch of
like salts for you to try definitely
definitely yeah i got yeah well i g i
gave him my address and he said
i'm really picky about the salt and and
he would laugh about this but the first
time he sent me salt i was i wasn't mean
but i was pretty intense about the fact
that it was not good salt and i was like
i'm not selling this and then because i
i always want to stick to the fact it's
easier said than done you know sometimes
if you get a big brand deal offer or
whatever but i always try to stick to
just i'm not going to promote it or do
anything with it unless i actually like
it and use it and that's true for this
all it's really good solved but i was
pretty intense at him at the start and i
almost didn't really do anything with it
i'm glad i did yeah but just the samples
we got early on were not as they weren't
that great they were up to par now
they're fantastic okay but and you were
telling me that you were considering
raising can you could you tell us a
little bit about the salt business and
and you were you were saying something
about the salt bay yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah so for the salt for raising
this all i mean
again
so this is after about six months we're
raising now um a little bit of money to
just bring a bunch of people on board to
try to really blow it up the whole goal
is to
is to shake up the salt game right just
kind of make make it new you like that
but like what are the margins because
you've been selling now like how much
how much do you make if someone buys
salt i mean
they're premium salts right so i think
even the cheapest one on the website
it's like 13.99 or something like that
um
and the cool thing is as you know right
noelle runs the kind of background and i
just my job is to make sure they're
really good salts and then just get
excited about get people excited about
it but um i mean the margins are great i
think the margins are really good on a
powder or salt or anything like that
all right yeah no yeah i mean the coffee
versus the salt but
um
but uh yeah i know it's great it's nice
to have the margin built-in too where
you can send it to people let them try
it get feedback get you know get it out
there more so it's really great and salt
bae is a different story so tell us
about this i just i don't know why i
just don't i don't like him i really
don't like him yeah have you ever seen
others no i've never seen him no he's in
he's in vegas right now yes i know yeah
are you gonna are you i could go see him
tonight if i wanted to if you go to if
you go and you order the gold stick i
think he comes out with it right now how
much is the gold stake
it's it's crazy so it's different in
every restaurant yeah but i mean like
you can one of them like 2 500 bucks
sometimes for like a mistake that's on
that place that's the cheapest thing you
can get so he goes to your oh it's
probably it can't be cheaper than 800 or
800 dollars
what's the restaurant called nusret new
n-u-s-r-e-t
it's it's
it's um it's just not good um you know
what the thing is the servers are the
nicest people ever he gets i gotta give
the guy credit he gives he gets really
great stuff i just think this stuff he
does is just a little bit odd like with
the he's like dry humping the table and
like
all that stuff you don't think that's a
little weird to play devil's advocate
you do have some you know sexual humor
in your like
so i found the prices okay so if you go
to the website here
salt baked golden tomahawk eleven
hundred dollars yeah i i cause i cook
with wagyu a lot and i'll get people
that come up on the street to say hi and
they asked me if i'm the wagyu guy which
goes to say like i cook a lot of wagyu
so i know the price of this stuff and i
i order lots of it i get lots of it
and
that's the other thing when you dive
really into the kind of food world in
cooking is that you know how much things
cost and when you go to a restaurant you
know if you're getting ripped off or not
or how let's say how badly you're
getting ripped off yeah and this place
is the worst of the worst so what's the
biggest criticism you don't like salt
bae
oh
here's the thing and be honest i don't
really have anything that i can totally
lay out and pinpoint on the guy in fact
he probably is a really nice guy i just
it
something about something about him you
know i watch the videos he's i i
the really you know
excessively high prices because frankly
that's that that gold leaf to cover that
stuff in
um
you can buy you can buy 10 sheets or 15
sheets of gold leaf for 23.25
so and that's all it takes to cover a
steak like that so just goes to show you
like there you can look at the normal
price of the time but see i look at that
i'm not paying for the gold and paying
for him to come to the table and
do do that you know i guess yeah but why
do you you want that it's like touch all
the salt's touching his elbow and do you
think he's keeping his elbow really
clean
you don't think so it adds flavor
see that's the thing i was kind of
curious about i'm like does he
constantly have to clean that because if
he doesn't that's kind of he does and
he's probably got it and he has hair
yeah he has hair and i see sometimes the
flakes get caught in his hair honestly
but would you not use that as an
opportunity to call him out and then
post that on youtube yeah
be like i think he would recognize
imagine
i think i'm probably on his team's radar
by now yeah so imagine you play because
we've made a couple of videos and we've
had i mean we've gotten we've gotten
pretty solid views on the these long
youtube videos and
let's put it this way the second time i
ever went to into one of his restaurants
it was like a different place um they
came they came over right away and they
they like knew they knew her or who they
knew what we were doing right they knew
who we were and um we were really polite
to them like they laughed about it that
i said listen guys i hope you know that
i'm giving your boss a hard time but
it's not nothing against you and they
all laughed and they just wanted us to
have a good time so i think we're
probably on his radar
um but we're getting his place publicity
yeah right you've never met him in
person
imagine if you posted a video
confronting salt bay just that's it
confronting salt bae at his rest i
thought about doing it while in vegas
yeah i just
i just um
i i it's a little awkward if he i don't
think he would know i don't think he'd
be like oh this is nick he's been making
fun of me he probably is absolutely you
know what you should what i do you know
it would be a banger video i'm talking
10 million views
if when he comes with his salt you give
him your salt be like could you put
myself oh
i like that idea
i actually took his he has one communal
restaurant salt shaker at the location
in boston
it's a big
it's a big uh salt bay figurine with the
hand like that and there's a hole in the
finger and i i undid it when there
weren't any servers and i poured it was
fresh it was fresh so sanitary fresh
thing of osmo my salt into the shaker
close it up last time i was there so he
was actually serving customers myself
the whole day which is kind of funny the
rest of the day
so you know a small win right there so
what's your schedule like now
because you're saying you know after
this you're going to go back to work
you're going to finish up some stuff
yeah what's a what's a typical day like
for you it's a good question
i
i film a lot i still film a lot um
i wake up probably i like my sleep i do
not function without probably eight and
a half nine hours of sleep i know it
sounds like a lot no it sounds sounds
reasonable to me yeah no i i just
there's no no point in you know
for me there's no point in trying to get
less because i do not function properly
if i don't get that much so i get my
sleep
i probably go to bed at midnight wake up
at like 8 39
and then
i shoot straight to the studio so i have
a studio um
three minutes four minutes away from
harvard campus actually so it's in a
good spot yeah and um and i i
i go to the studio i film from usually
10 a.m to probably
probably 3 34 p.m and um and then i
usually have 4 35
until i'm usually on the phone or
working until at least
10 p.m every night it's it's always a
long day
um
so
yeah i would say i work consistently
consistently
probably
12 to 14 hour days probably how many
days a week
five and sometimes i'll take a sunday to
go film nice to catch up yeah what about
your good old friend work ethic my
girlfriend yeah she
does investment banking so she works
she's gone 80 hours yeah yeah yeah she
works more hours than i do it's kind of
nice though because i don't feel crazy
about working the amount that i do
because even i mean even
even
the 12 to 14 hour days you don't really
have much extra time to do like much
else that's crazy so how do you have a
relationship when she works 70 to 80
hours a week and you're working your
schedule how do you find time for each
other how long have you guys been
together for
three over a little over three years
okay i mean
uh
we're both just i mean we're both young
or kind of just on the move right now
you know so it kind of works pretty well
in that sense but
um
and we have a puppy and we have a
hamster so things are just you know
there's a lot going on but
have you ever found it challenging
though with the schedules because your
schedule of working like this i mean you
guys got together before
yeah met crazy yeah in college she was
on the volleyball team i think we met in
the gym or something and then
um
you know the rest of her sister well i
met her a week before i left to
masterchef so no one at school yet had a
clue that i was gonna go do that which
is kind of fun and then i left for like
three and a half months she thought you
ghosted her yeah i know a lot of people
did that did you did you not tell her no
no her i told but
a lot of people thought i was ghosting
them or my best friends actually
from from years ago that i hadn't kept
things super close touchers but that i i
ended up living with him after college
he he said he invited me to a patriots
game he said he asked me to come to a
red sox game he's like i didn't hear
back from he said he invited me to his
birthday party on my phone so i felt bad
he was like wouldn't he contact your
parents yeah why was going on with me
why didn't you give your phone to like
your parents and be like just respond
back to people someone's gone right
don't you don't you agree like
you know what i mean if i didn't hear
from a close friend for three months
i would find a way i'd show up at their
house
he just thought i just had written him
off but again i hadn't i hadn't enjoyed
it it would have been one of my
roommates or something
um
but yeah i just don't pay rent for three
months yeah yeah no i mean it's crazy to
leave for that long but
it's it's was kind of nice
but you but you guys don't have any
challenges with like the work schedule
or anything like maintaining a
relationship while working this no it's
actually it's nice it's it's good cool
um
just both working that much and and and
seeing how many hours she has to work
um the worst stretch of time was like 5
a.m until
till
5 a.m till maybe
five
so sorry she would wake up at like maybe
eight nine am and then work till five
a.m every morning for two weeks straight
that was the worst period that i saw in
there why don't you want to go into
investment banking i have no idea money
no she's not like that she's not like no
no why then why go into it i feel like
everyone goes into investment banking
because they just think
best money no i i think i mean yes i
think a lot of people do i think she i
think she just wants to do this sort of
venture capital type stuff and if to do
that theoretically you really need to
put in those hard years of like i got
beat up and i and i handle it and i you
know came out the other end in one piece
type thing yeah i think that's what it
is you got to be really strong to have
to do that for investment banking pretty
awful yeah yeah youtube is obviously a
grind everyone thinks that the stuff
that we do for
let's say the social media world is just
sort of a walk in the park it's really
stressful
it's intense yeah it is
it's hard so first i would say the first
three years or that's the golden era so
you gotta you got another two years to
go man yeah
yeah i mean i'm milking it right now i'm
i'm i'm working a lot
but and i'm having fun
but it's tiring oh oh uh here's a good
question how much how much of that are
you saving or spending oh man
i had some i had some big spending
months towards the end of december not i
don't buy i don't buy fancy crazy stuff
i'm really not i'm a nice car that's the
only thing i have no i have a nice
i actually just traded a model 3 for the
i just traded a model 3 for the model x
plaid
to be over 6000 pounds for the right wow
you got the model x plaid yeah the new
redesigned one yeah oh i want to see
that
it's a cool car wow you drove here no no
i'm because i'm from boston but oh man i
wanted i was hoping it was parked out
because i wanted to see the new like the
new design on the internet it's a badass
car and that's a good question because
that's the that's the one kind of nice
thing i look you know i don't pay
anything crazy for my monthly rent for
my apartment i pay the same as i think
everyone else does in boston um
i spend all the same twenty thousand
dollars a month
i spend all the money on
on
i really do on on on
on the team i spend i spend a lot on
food and eating at restaurants and that
kind of stuff too which i i see is you
know i'm not going i'm not going to
buying the gold stake at salt bays
unless it's for a video but i'm i'm
um
i
i would say i save
i would say i save about
realistically about 50 of it maybe a
little bit more maybe 55-60 percent of
what comes in which is i don't know if
that's good or bad you you you
you obviously would but yeah it's it
seems like there's high expenses because
your income is so good super high
expenses where's the money going how
i mean
the team's getting pretty big now so the
editor makes a lot of money um and and
you know the operations person the
assistant all that stuff i i i am of the
mindset that i should be you know paying
everyone
on the highest range that i can't really
can be right for like what they should
be making and then i give people nice
bonuses and that kind of stuff too um
and then
and then you know i'm buying a lot of
crazy ingredients that stuff is
expensive right the the
three thousand dollar prime wheel like
wow you there's just your accountant
must love this
it's crazy how is i bet your taxes last
year were
who does your taxes how do they do that
the same guy that does i think mr b
stuff so he's well versed in the youtube
world which is good but
things probably get a little wild i mean
i was spending a lot of money in
november december
last year it was crazy
but i was also making a lot of videos
and doing a lot of crazy
stuff in the video so and how are you
like saving your money are you investing
it or are you just holding it i invest
almost all my money
for better first in um
in tesla
yeah wow
how long have you been doing that for
since i was
since i probably started high school are
you serious maybe a little bit before
yeah how many years has this been now
um started high school 10 maybe before
that even maybe like because i remember
i think i made five thousand dollars
what year is either yeah i think i made
five thousand dollars my freshman year
of high school in the summer and i put
all that into tesla and then what year
was that give us a year i graduated high
school i graduated college 2019 high
school 2015 so let's say 20 2011 maybe
yeah 2011 tesla would have been i don't
know 20 dollars a share all right i
don't remember that was but yeah it's
split
split now so like
i was just like
everyone's gonna be curious about this
let me take a look at this guess how
much tesla was in 2011 jack
oh um
i don't know i actually have 50 bucks to
share
four dollars and 46 cents i don't think
i got in that low yes but you did
because it's the split you're forgetting
about the split okay so it would be four
times five so twenty dollars that would
have been the price back then but then
it split so then you got five to one
that sounds right so you bought it at
four dollars now
that means that on those early
investments you got like a 20 000 return
yeah i probably made a lot on those
early ones but i didn't put all 5000 in
but yeah i put i i
i
um
i put pretty much all of that in there
probably i messed around at some points
by the way like i would like try to play
you know i would try to
be all fancy with it and um
and definitely got burned a couple times
doing that but um i met this guy who who
had been
um i think employee number
between four and seven at tesla and he
built the first one long time ago super
nice guy i randomly met him one summer
and um
and after that i was like all in on it
and i also really was into environmental
science always always have been climate
change all that stuff so i'm a big fan
of it so yeah i
i am and then not long after that i met
some guy who was his whole life he's he
was some
mit
mit professor hot shot or something he's
his whole life is supposedly just
invested in apple no not like everything
always apple so it's like okay maybe
it's not the dumbest strategy ever so
it's not very diversified but i put it
on tesla still wow still yeah
yeah generally speaking i think i do a
pretty good job of trying to save the
money but i also
you know i'm not scared to just put it
into content and hope that you know with
calculated um guesses hope that it pays
off you know i've had yeah videos that
haven't paid off and haven't worked but
in general i think they do pretty well
so um based on the investment so yeah
wow what questions do you have for us
we could always flip the script if you
have any questions how stupid is it to
put all my money in tesla uh
out of one one of the ten stupid i mean
the thing is i would say it's it's not
the best choice but since you make
a decent amount of money
and your expenses are kind of like
relative to how much money you make
and you live frugally i mean it's not
the worst i mean even if tesla were to
drop 80 percent
you would be fine you know
it wouldn't be a big deal and you're and
you're young enough where well i mean it
would be a big deal but you would be
okay it's not like you know you're gonna
lose your house or you're gonna be on
the street like you're making enough
that
what you make will offset any bad
investments so as long as you don't
screw up the income like
you'll be fine if it were me you've
already kind of won the game on that
and i would probably take half
and do a broad index fund and just 50 50
it that way you're still 50 in tesla 50
diversified but that that other 50 is
like that's your foundation yeah and no
matter what happens anything else like
you got that 50 just locked away yeah
that's what i would do
yeah
the the the interesting and kind of
scary part of social media i don't know
if you ever have this feeling
the sort of that feeling that that at
any point in time everyone that's
watching all your stuff could just sort
of go away that's right every day for me
everybody has that feeling yeah and and
and
and at some point you know things may
fizzle off and it's probably a scary
thing if and when it does but
but the hardest part sort of in my mind
is always like all right i'm i'm
i should be continuing to build out this
team and i am but you know what if that
thing happens what if that day happens
and then i don't have the money coming
in to pay that team all of a sudden or
something like that it's always a
question in my mind right yeah but
that's why you're living frugally and
saving yeah so
yeah so i do have that sort of that
thing on the side as a backup but
financially i mean as long as you save
that 50 in like an index fund you're
going to be less concerned about if
people stop watching at least
financially yeah because then you'll be
like wow i've saved the majority of it
uh my whole philosophy is just take it
like month by month
uh or even year by year sometimes and
just be like you know whatever happens
happens but at least you've
you've um
you you know you did you did your best
yeah so yeah you saved it all i like
that yeah
yeah no i'm trying i'm trying to save
but again i put a lot of it into the to
the videos and and to the team and to
all the stuff that we're doing so
you know there's months where i look
back and i'm like i spent way too much
money this month but i look back on what
we did and what i spent today what are
the expenses like just on a normal month
would you say like including food and
50 grand yeah i mean there's been months
or yeah i mean there's been months where
if we've traveled and if i buy all these
crazy ingredients and like we're doing
renovations on the studio i mean like
doing home renovation type things is
crazy like i got a 22 000 bill the other
day for that it's insane so yeah it just
it fluctuates a lot i would say it
fluctuates a lot but yeah it can be it
can be pretty solid do you consider
yourself more of an influencer or a chef
that's a really good question
thank you
you're welcome
and that's it it's an interesting
question what's the next one
never thought of it like that good
question
um
i mean this is sort of a
a
silly way maybe to answer the question
but i like to think of myself as someone
who
who
who you know
influences people to cook to cook more
um
and
and so
it's honestly about finding that kind of
fine line between you know making
making legit enough recipes that you
know that the actual chefs out there you
know who are let's say actual chefs
cooking at a restaurant every day that
kind of thing aren't you know
aren't laughing too much at you and and
um have some respect for what you're
doing and then at the same time the
other side of it is like again trying to
play that influencer side of things
where you're getting enough views to
make this whole thing work you know what
i mean
um
if i put out a really boring video of me
making uh you know potato soup
no one's gonna really watch it because
it's not that exciting but if i have
that sexy parmesan wheel that i you know
crack open a lobster and make a lobster
risotto inside or something right
then suddenly you got a lot of people
watching so it so
that's a long way of saying i feel like
i feel like i try to ride the line
between both of those things and make
sure that i'm not going too far onto
either side if that makes sense
i'm wondering if there's any animosity
between like chefs that are like in the
trenches in the kitchen you know
definitely always going to be the
influencer chefs you know like how they
don't respect you guys there have to be
at the same time though
i feel like
there's a point in time where there's
sort of an inflection point and a lot of
those chefs that i thought would have
that kind of animosity
really like and respect what i'm doing
at least to my face i i hope that that's
how they really feel but um you know
their kids are watching some of the
videos and maybe trying to you know ask
to cook more a little bit because of it
hopefully um so i i think actually
i saw an inflection point where i kind
of felt like oh they're all going to be
looking at me and
you know
mad at what i'm doing just because i'm
you know i'm not supposed to throw the
knife into the cutting marks it's
ruining the tip of the knife and they're
all probably just right but in reality
actually i've had a pretty good response
from all the super legit you know
restaurant train chefs that i know so
um and i also worked in three or four
restaurants to get that that
rigorous training just so i could have
that side of everything so you know i
think i've
hopefully done a good job of trying to
think of it from a broader perspective
and not piss anyone off along the way
too much and when you do go to
restaurants do you find yourself like
studying the food and like looking into
it and maybe decoding how they made it
or do you just kind of sit and enjoy it
as a normal person well i mean i can see
themes in any menu like you know
if if um often times if um
uh
if you look carefully at a menu you'll
see i mean unless it's the cheesecake
factor or something that has a giant
there it's all frozen and all that stuff
and it's it is
that she's here yeah yeah graham's like
i know selling all my stuff are you
serious cheesecake factory you got a lot
of cheesecakes that's just they have
some special oven they put every single
thing in really do you know that for a
fact
yeah it's frozen you should look it up
but it's wrong oh yeah i loved him
specifically that i love the cheesecake
factory i got the miso salmon and that
was one of like my favorite things
probably frozen miso oh yeah well i know
a lot of fish is flash frozen but yeah
well either way um
no because you always say
no no because you always see the chefs
in the back with the big flame
i mean i'm sure there's a cop it's just
a flame thrower dude
it's all for sure let me ask you a
question yeah do you think in a
restaurant that big with probably not a
ridiculously sized kitchen staff they
can put out that many food items quickly
if a lot of it's not frozen i don't know
i just thought it was a high turnover
like enough people order the lemon
chicken
that they just kind of no no
frozen but
um
yeah um
i i i so i see themes and menus like for
instance there you know there may be a
there may be a
um
it's really easy with a sushi restaurant
for example because you know they can
take an entire tuna let's say and break
it down and you know a spicy tuna roll
that's um when they scrape off those
last kind of parts between the between
the um
between the skeleton right of the fish
in the middle um that fillet when you're
getting between the bones that's when
you scrape off all the stuff and that
mushy bit you can't serve that on a nice
piece of nigiri or anything that's a
spicy that's where you get spicy tuna
spicy salmon it's all mushed in and they
can add extra stuff in there you don't
really know so
they repurpose all the different things
so i can see that theme in menus where
i'm like oh okay like i see they use
some of the lobster they use the lobster
stock and this in this
piece of the whole menu and they have
this here and this here but and then the
lobster roll has like that nice you know
you know they might take the nice claw
piece for the top of a lobster pasta and
then they might take the chopped up bits
for the lobster rolls and then they
might take the last part for right so
there's some interesting stuff like that
but i'm not picky
and i'm not i never go to a restaurant
and make fun of it or anything like that
do you strategically order when you go
to restaurants for example like if
you're ordering in like the midwest you
know maybe you're not ordering like some
fish or something like that i won't get
oysters if it's not at some good seafood
place but maybe by the water and i know
they're fresh and
same with like i'm not going to order
meat at a you know at a restaurant and
on the water in seattle yeah and give a
go-to
for yeah order uh my favorite food my
favorite food is rotisserie chicken um i
really love rotisserie chicken that's it
okay she's so bland what
where are you getting the registered
chickens i don't even know what that is
safeway
i don't know i mean i know they're good
at costco whole foods and
really i love rochester chickens but oh
i don't really have a go-to or i'm very
strategic with the menus that's
interesting anytime i go anywhere that
has a burger on the menu that's what i
ordered really and i would love to
expand my like you know interests and
like all these other types of like
definitely a way to be strategic about
it but it's just like i know i like
burgers and so every time i go to a
restaurant with a burger i just get it
yeah that's fine there's something wrong
with that what's your favorite
restaurant like ever yeah if if someone
wants to go to a restaurant in the u.s
or like this is the best place i've been
to
best place i've been to in the us
besides super sushi here in las vegas
what's that oh it's in all you could eat
that's really it's all i could eat sushi
spot that we would go to yeah
um
my favorite restaurants are
i don't i wouldn't have one in
particular i'd have ones for different
cuisines maybe but
the hole in the wall type places i i
went through a phase in my life where i
like the fancy places because you're
like oh man i'm into food so i want to
go to the fine dining at the foam and
all that fancy stuff and now i i really
don't like those experiences okay i'm
not a fan um they cost a lot they take a
long time and
a lot of it has started to get a little
bit lost on me but
but a really good just whether it's a
thai place or a peruvian place for just
these nice ceviches and you know
plantain chips to scoop them up with
peruvian place whatever um
those are always my favorite so
i mean bring me like somewhere it
doesn't have to be fancy but fresh and
and
i mean yeah fresh and maybe a little
creative and and just good good food i'm
happy
cool yeah
all right anything else jack
i think that's uh i think that's pretty
good do you have any other do you think
there are more wheels in the world or
more doors in the world
oh you're asking me this question yeah
i think i answered this yesterday i
think i said wheels
i think i said wheels okay okay wheels
yeah what's the correct answer
i don't know if there's one well uh yeah
it's it's definitely wheels and if uh is
it the thing it stores then you're
definitely then why is there a debate
and why because people like to be wrong
oh well that sounds like confidence i
don't think they're ever gonna find the
real answer to that question would you
rather fight
uh one horse-sized duck or 100
duck-sized horses oh well by the way it
was wheels
like there's not just like
how do they know yeah
what if i have like a thousand
because some websites
what if i just said it's actually from a
car insurance company car insurance
comparison super app jerry is here to
end the debate i think i'd probably
fight the um the big duck we can
estimate there are many 33 billion doors
in the world between uh doors in the
world between houses apartment buildings
vehicles cabinets closets and other
compartments
uh but wheels there are 37 billion a lot
of wheels yeah yeah
he's you know i asked him the horse and
duck yes he said he would rather fight
the big oh you're not weird that's
strange i'd be so scared of a bunch of
mini horses really there's a lot of them
yeah you can plow through them though i
don't know one big duck that's actually
a thing they knocked you down you're
you're done
they somehow knocked you down yeah
they're not going to knock you down
you're probably right yeah
all right so with that said have you got
your free stock in public
no worth all the way up to a thousand
dollars when you sign up using the link
down below in the description with a
good gram
and you get your bankroll
okay all right all right thank you so
much for coming on now we really
appreciate this you made the drive out
here really nice meeting you thank you
guys smash the like button check him out
down below check out osmo salt okay yeah
it looks really good i've never had it
but it looks amazing yes very good shout
outs to noelle to make that yeah happen
good work noel thanks nick thank you
guys thanks oh and then before we take a
thumbnail picture oh let's do it what do
we do